the subject of this segment is the
calculation of the PMF of the sum of two
independent discrete random variables
this is the simplest example of a
function of two random variables a
function of the form G of X and Y where
the function G happens to be just the
sum of the two arguments this is a very
important example because there are many
situations where random variables get
added to each other we work with
discrete random variables as a warm-up
and later we will consider the case of
continuous random variables so suppose
that we know the PMF of X and Y and that
we want to compute the probability that
the sum is equal to 3 it always helps to
have a picture the sum of x and y will
be equal to 3 this is an event that can
happen in many ways for example X could
be 3 and Y could be 0 or X could be 1
and Y be equal to 2 the probability of
the event of interest that the sum is
equal to 3 is going to be the sum of the
probabilities of all the different ways
that this event can happen so it is
going to be a sum of various terms and
the typical term will be the probability
let's say of this outcome which is that
X is equal to 0 and Y is equal to 3
another typical term in the sum will be
the probability of this outcome here the
probability that X is equal to 1 Y is
equal to 2 and so on now here comes an
important step because we have assumed
that x and y are independent the
probability of these two events
happening is the product of the
probabilities of each one of these
events so it is the product of the
probability that X is equal to 0 who are
now I'm using PMF notation times the
probability that Y is equal to 3
similarly the next term is the
probability that X is equal to 1 times
the probability that y is equal to 2
again we can do this because we are
assuming that our two random variables
are independent of
now let us generalize in the general
case the probability that the sum takes
on a particular value little Z can be
calculated as follows
we look at all the different ways that
the sum of little Z can be obtained one
way is that the random variable X takes
on specific value little X and at the
same time the random variable Y takes
the value that's needed so that the sum
of the two is equal to little Z for a
given value of x of little X we have a
particular way that the sum is equal to
Z and this particular way has a certain
probability but little X could be
anything and different choices of little
X give us different ways that the event
of interest can happen so we add those
probabilities over all possible X's and
then we proceed as follows we invoke
Independence of x and Y to write this
probability as a product of two
probabilities and then we use PMF
notation instead of probability notation
to obtain this expression here this
formula is called the convolution
formula it is the convolution of two
pmfs
what convolution means is that somebody
gives us the PMF of one random variable
gives us also the PMF of another random
variable and when we say were given the
PMF it means were given the values of
the PMF for all possible choices of
little X and little Y the arguments of
the two pmfs then the convolution
formula does a certain calculation and
spits out now a new PMF which is the PMF
of the random variable Z let us now take
a closer look of what it takes to carry
out the calculations involved in this
convolution formula let us proceed by a
simple example that will
the methodology were given to pmf's of
two random variables and assuming that
they're independent the PMF of their sum
is determined by this formula here and
we want to see what those terms in this
summation would be suppose that were
interested in the probability that the
sum is equal to three now the sum is it
going to be equal to three this can
happen in several ways we could have X
equal to 1 and y equal to 2 this
combination is one way that the sum of
three can be obtained and that
combination has a probability of 1/3
times 3 sixths and that would be one of
the terms in this summation another way
that the sum of 3 can be obtained is by
having X equal to 4 and y equal to minus
1 and by multiplying this probability
2/3 with 2/6 we obtain another
contribution to this summation however
keeping track of these correspondences
here can become a little complicated if
we have richer pmfs so an alternative
way of arranging the calculation is the
following let us take the PMF of Y flip
it along this vertical axis so these two
terms will go to the left side and this
term will go to the right hand side and
then draw it underneath the PMF of X
this is what we obtain then let us take
this drawing here and shift it to the
right by 3 so the entry of -2 goes to 1
minus 1 goes to 2 and 1 goes to 4 so
what have we accomplished by these two
transformations well the term that had
probability three sixths and which were
to be multiplied with the probability
1/3
on that side now these three sixths sits
here so we have this correspondence and
we need to multiply 1/3 by 3 sixths
similarly the multiplication of 2/3 with
2 sixths corresponds to the
multiplication of this problem
here times the probability of this term
here so when the diagrams are arranged
this way then we have a simpler job to
do we look at corresponding terms those
that sit on top of each other
multiply them do that for all possible
choices and then add those products
together and this is what we do if we're
shifting by three now if we wanted to
find the probability that is equal to
four we would be doing the same thing
except that this diagram would need to
be shifted by one more unit to the right
so that we have a total shift of four so
we just repeat this procedure for all
possible values of Z which corresponds
to taking this diagram here and shifting
it progressively by different amounts
this turns out to be a fairly simple and
systematic way of arranging the
calculations at least if you are doing
them by hand of course an alternative is
to carry out the calculations on a
computer this is a pretty simple formula
that is not hard to implement on a
computer